Elon Musk is famous for his drive, but now he wants the rest of us...
...to take our hands off the wheel.
He's bringing out fully self-driving Teslas.
Well, at least autonomous ready.
This isn't just a software upgrade,...
...which is how Tesla has updated its autonomous capabilities in the past.
This is new hardware that includes eight cameras...
...for a full 360-degree view of the environment,...
...and enhanced ultrasonic sensors, as well as a huge bump in computing power.
Musk is making typically big claims.
He says that by the end of next year, he'll demonstrate a car...
...that can drive from L.A. to New York all without the driver,...
...or is it a passenger by that point, touching a thing.
The full set of features will come at a cost, $8,000.